[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
décentralisation le sénat marre que le
projet de loi 3ds de son empreinte
transition écologique logement santé et
si dans tous ces domaines les élus
locaux bénéficiaient désormais de plus
grandes marges de manoeuvre
réuni le 31 janvier 2022 députés et
sénateurs ont trouvé un accord sur le
projet de loi de décentralisation 3ds
parce que le texte manqué d'ambition le
sénat est allé plus loin en faveur des
territoires
sa recette les 50 propositions pour le
plein exercice des libertés locales
qu'il avait présentée dès juillet 2020
après avoir consulté les élus locaux
sur des points majeurs le texte issu de
la commission mixte paritaire entérine
des avancées défendue par le sénat
et surtout qui était attendue de longue
date par les élus
prenons un premier exemple les éoliennes
grâce à l'action du sénat les maires
auront désormais les moyens d'encadrer
leur implantation
pour cela ils s'appuieront sur les plans
locaux d'urbanisme
autre exemple en matière de logement
social
le rythme de construction sera désormais
négocier avec la signature d'un contrat
de mixité sociale adaptée entre l'état
et les maires
pour les routes nationales
le sénat a aussi obtenu un transfert en
priorité aux départements en
coordination avec les régions
dans le même temps les communes
choisiront plus librement les
compétences qu'elles veulent mutualiser
c'est ça l'intercommunalité
elle se fera au plus près du terrain
cette proximité elle s'appliquera dans
les domaines du tourisme et de la voirie
en particulier
outre les maires ruraux le rôle du
préfet de département sera renforcée car
c'est la logique de déconcentration de
l'état qui doit primer
voilà la marque des travaux du sénat nos
apports dans ce nouveau texte
c'est un pas supplémentaire sur la voie
d'un renforcement de la décentralisation
c'est aussi un gage d'efficacité pour
les politiques publiques sur les
territoires
mais pour l'avenir disons le une réforme
plus ambitieuse reste plus que jamais
nécessaire
pour en savoir plus consultez les
apports du sénat
[Musique]